le syndrome de la tourette n'a pas de
traité mais on peut vivre avec
[Musique]
je crois qu un colocataire te fera du
bien pour ne pas être seul alex et voici
face à force de se relever les jeux
seraient colocataires quelques temps tél
qu'est-ce que tu ferais si tu contrôler
mieux tu éthiques
[Musique]
quelle différence ça peut faire moi j'en
ferai une moi c'est marie je dois te
faire visiter la clinique val d or die
sa connexion pourri salle de télé aucune
chaîne câblée salle de jeu mais ils sont
tous des bills tu peux y aller alors
pourquoi tu manges rien détends toi le
fait qu'elle est entre pour moi c'est
mission impossible
tu prends tu pouvais aller tu voulais
tirer ou voir le sait
[Musique]
votre fils est parti commencent à
apporter il a pris ma voiture
les deux autres de nos patients sont
partis
centre et là je sais pas s'il sera
capable bar de nuit pour être
intéressant mais c'est fichu rituel me
lâche pas et le second c'est moi je me
crois grosse on a tous des soucis
si c'était nous et si c'était génial et
si c'était dangereux temmar et si
c'était sensationnel pour simon moore à
butin et si on vivait alors
[Musique]
baa
je devrais pas au moins tirer un peu
partie de cette caste maladie vient de
dire quatre phrases sans un seul espace
mais là je serai au moins dix fois alors
quelle différence
[Musique]